a football pitch in El Salvador that
should have been hosting a quarter-final
match instead transformed into a chaotic
triage Center
at first we thought it was a fire
started by the Alianza fans but it was
actually an avalanche of people at the
Saul entrance some witnesses say there
were too many people and that fans tried
to push through a gate into the
kwescateland stadium
the match in San Salvador was called off
after just 16 minutes those who survived
the crash tried desperately to revive
the injured
with such an overcrowding and the
slowness at the entrance approximately
400 to 500 people gathered and in the
eagerness to watch the game some fans
wanted to open the gate and when they
opened it a swarm formed some of us call
it a stampede
survivors say they were trampled and
almost suffocated some say they'll never
go back to the stadium
emergency workers report about 500
people received medical treatment
and a hundred of them were taken to
hospital in a serious condition
unfortunately there were children
elderly people they were the ones who
were harmed there are people who have
been given first aid and the biggest
responsibility now is on the authority
the football federations called off all
national games scheduled for Sunday
president Naye bukhile has ordered an
investigation warning that anyone
responsible will be punished for now the
Salvadoran football Community is in
mourning
Alexia O'Brien Al Jazeera